[Musique]
c'est le chiffre qu'on redoutait en
compte ce soir 4857 mort ou disparu sous
les décombres encore fumants du world
trade center à new york et 200 morts à
washington chiffres provisoires en
direct avec nous un rescapé français
bruno dellinger il l'a quitté l'immeuble
30 secondes avant son effondrement
la piste remonté par le fbi il passe par
l'allemagne deux des kamikazes auraient
séjourné hambourg
information france 2 dans un document
adressé il ya quatre jours à toutes les
ambassades le département d'état
américain mettait en garde contre des
actions terroristes menées par des
groupes proches de ben laden
en france une vingtaine d' alerte à la
bombe aujourd'hui on reviendra
longuement sur l'impact de ces images de
terrorisme sur les enfants il faut leur
parler disent les psychiatres et puis
cérémonie inter religieuse à la mémoire
des victimes à paris valéry giscard
d'estaing y est si ce fait l'ancien
président sera l'invité de questions
ouvertes à 20h40 envoyée spéciale
reviendra ensuite longuement sur
l'internationale terroriste
bonsoir à tous et merci de votre
attention rudolf giuliani le maire de
new york l'a annoncé il ya quelques
heures d'une voix blanche
le bilan de l'attentât du world trade
center s'élève ce soit 4763 disparu et
94 morts bilan évidemment provisoire les
secouristes s'affairent
on vient de retirer plusieurs personnes
des décombres dont une jeune femme de 24
ans les dernières images commentées par
daniel wolfromm
un immense nuage de poussière flottent
depuis deux jours sur le sud de
manhattan
l'image est prise depuis un hublot de
l'appareil du président de lituanie
un des rares avions autorisés à survoler
new york ce matin mais sous le nuage
il n'y a plus rien ou presque sur champ
de ruines et tout ce qui reste du world
trade center sur place une multitude de
sauveteurs safer pêle-mêle des gardes
nationaux des policiers des pompiers
secouristes en tous genres qui extraient
les premiers corps et dégage les
miraculés comme ce policier
le bruit de l'immeuble sans abri y ait
quitté sans des je me suis dit ça y est
c'est foutu je me suis forcée alors à
sortir fallait que j'arrive pièce par
pièce
le travail est minutieux et titanesque à
la fois au regard de la taille du
chantier c'est le jour mais il fait nuit
noire sous la chape de poussière la
voûte du hall du centre financier il ya
trois jours c'était encore une des
arcades les plus prestigieuses de new
york
des graffitis au détour d'un couloir
dieu bénisse nos frères inscriptions
griffonné à la hâte par des pompiers en
hommage à leur collègue mauricie par
dizaines quand les tours se sont
effondrées mardi
soudain c'est la leyre sauve qui peut
général des immeubles fragilisés
menacent toujours de s'écrouler
aujourd'hui mais les recherches
reprennent vestiges du drame qui s'est
passé ici ces empilements de véhicules
brûlés et cette atmosphère toujours
aussi respirable
c'est pourtant dans un de ces véhicules
de secours ensevelies sous des étages de
gravats que cinq pompiers viennent ce
soir d'être retrouvé vivant pendant deux
jours ils ont vécu protégé par cette
carcasse les sauveteurs qui se relaient
équipe après équipes sont en train de
les sortir des décombres
oui on ne perd pas espoir donc le groupe
de réassurance français scor estime par
ailleurs que le coût des attentats sera
compris entre 10 et 15 milliards de
dollars un chiffre pour résumer la
mobilisation et la solidarité des
américains les ventes de drapeaux et se
sont envolés la plus grande chaîne de
supermarchés en a vendu 116000 pour la
seule journée de mardi contre 6000 en
moyenne par jour
un drapeau souvent en berne placés sur
les voitures ou les maisons new york qui
se serrent les coudes reportage philippe
gassot tristan le bras sur le site même
du world trade center ses jours et nuits
que les sauveteurs travaillent car ce
qui est engagée ici c'est une course
contre la mort il y à des survivants là
dessous c'est certain il faut faire vite
les masses à déplacer sont énormes
dehors de l'autre côté du périmètre de
sécurité dans la poussière même si l'on
craint l'amiante
une petite foule vient chaque soir elle
est ici pour glaner de trop rares bonnes
nouvelles ces américains viennent
surtout pour encourager les sauveteurs
montrer qu'ils sont là à leurs côtés que
la solidarité est sans faille
chaque geste même le plus petit revêt
ici son importance des remerciements
écrit sur les murs elle a commencé seul
à coller ses affiches
maintenant on vient l'aider qu'est ce
que je pouvais faire pour les aider moi
ça fait dix-huit heures qu'il travaille
peut-être qu'en voyant ça ils iront un
peu mieux pour chacun l'important c'est
d'être là de participer de montrer que
l'on n'est pas indifférent aux malheurs
des autres quitte à oublier ses propres
problèmes
j'habite juste à côté du world trade
center j'ai voulu rentrer chez moi pour
récupérer des affaires mais on m'a pas
laissé rentrer pour des raisons de
sécurité parfois l'émotion est trop
forte on craque mais on reste pourquoi
pleures tél parce qu'ici c'est ma maison
devant les hôpitaux dans cette ville qui
a retrouvé toute sa vitalité des
milliers de familles se raccroche à la
moindre espérance
les affichettes d'ordinateurs sont
placardées partout on attend un appel
qui tiendrait du miracle mais impossible
de ne pas y croire
il cherche son fils de 21 ans qui
travaillait dans le world trade
je sais qu'il y à des appels de
téléphones portables qui viennent des
ruines du world trade center
or il se trouve que mon fils tommy avait
un téléphone portable on sait donc qu'il
ya des signes de vie qui viennent des
ruines
aujourd'hui nous espérons j'espère que
mon fils ait parmi les survivants
le chiffre des disparus dépasse les 5000
personnes
les morts officiellement constaté sont
près de 100 ici on se demande pourquoi
philippe gassot il est deux heures de
l'après midi chez vous est ce qu ont
circulé ce qu'on travaille à nouveau
normalement à new york dans la zone qui
n'est pas directement touché par
l'effondrement des deux tours
eh bien écoutez ce matin à new york a
repris son activité et on l'a constaté
par des encombrements énorme car un
tiers de manhattan et hors circulation
donc il est laid très difficile de se
déplacer donc manifestement new york est
retourné au travail je parlais ce matin
à une jeune femme qui était venu nous
voir ici alors on lui demandant alors
comment ça va se passer ce retour au
travail parce que elle n'avait pas
regagné son bureau hier et elle m'a dit
c'est vrai surtout de travailler mais ça
ne sera jamais plus comme avant
ici les américains portent en eux une
profonde tristesse
on parlait des drapeaux américains qui
se vendent c'est vrai on voit un peu
partout des drapeaux américains
on voit des pompiers qui met le drapeau
américain sur leur casque on voit des
gens qui arbore le tee shirt avec le
drapeau américain
tout cela montre que l'on résiste hier
le maire de
de new york demandé aux américains de
vivre normalement c'est à dire d'aller
au cinéma d'aller au théâtre d'aller au
café de ne pas avoir peur
en fait ils appelaient la population de
new york à résister à résister contre
ces terroristes qui veulent changer le
monde et qui vole qui menace j'allais
dire le monde libre en frappant les
symboles américains
du côté de giuliani ont dit vous êtes
new yorkais vous êtes des durs continuer
comme si de rien n'était même si c'est
très difficile
merci philippe images de washington
maintenant la nuit dernière plusieurs
centaines de personnes se sont
rassemblées devant la maison blanche
pour une balade pour une veillée de
deuil bougie à la main chantant l'hymne
américain pour montrer au monde je cite
que les américains resteront unis
l'ambiance aujourd'hui dans la capitale
américaine reportage etienne leenhardt
aronian ils sont venus spontanément et
le magasin ce matin ne désemplissait pas
la bannière étoilée est devenu le signe
de ralliement d'une amérique touché de
plein fouet et déstabilise alors que le
deuil commence à peine le drapeau
américain se vend depuis quelques heures
à des centaines de milliers
d'exemplaires chacun veut se montrer
solidaire j'ai essayé de racheter 1 hier
soir il était en rupture de stock donc
je suis venu maintenant pour être sûr
d'en avoir un on va le mettre devant
l'église avec un signe que dieu bénisse
l'amérique depuis trois jours cette dame
est sans nouvelles de son genre chamonix
est directement touché ses parties des
pompes le disparu à new york
au sommet du pentagone éventré c'est
encore lui qui sonne la révolte demain
pour une journée nationale de deuil
l'amérique est appelée à s'habiller en
rouge blanc bleu a accroché où que l'on
se trouve un drapeau aux fenêtres à le
coudre sur un vêtement pour tenter
autant que faire se peut de se relever
notre patriotisme il est toujours
présent simplement il s'exprime beaucoup
plus fort en ce moment devant le monde
entier c'est une preuve de notre courage
solidaire et déstabiliser brièvement ce
matin l'on a autorisé certains passagers
des avions cloués au sol à venir
chercher leur bagage abandonné mardi
matin dans la panique des évacuations et
qui ne savent pas quand ils pourront
rentrer chez eux mais je n'ai plus de
ses envies de le faire mme franchement
je me sentirais plus rassurés s'ils ne
mettaient un policier en uniforme dans
chaque appareil pour assurer plus que
pour défendre la garde nationale restent
postés à tous les carrefours de la
capitale américaine
il est des blessures qu'il ne se
refermeront jamais etienne vous attiriez
aussi notre attention hors antenne sur
les enfants à washington où ailleurs
peut-être et sur le choc qu'ils avaient
encaissé
oui david vous savez washington
s'apprête à rentrer dans une nuit et une
journée demain de deuil puisque ce
vendredi sera une journée de deuil
national en amérique mais ce matin ce
sont d'autres professionnels qui se sont
remis au travail les enseignants puisque
toutes les écoles à washington ont
rouvert et que les enfants dans le huis
clos des classes et à l'abri des médias
qui se sont tous volontairement tenu à
l'écart et bien les enfants ont été
invités à apposer les questions pour
tenter d'extérioriser cette
incompréhension cette peur aussi que
popper aussi pardon que que les adultes
et que tous les enfants du monde ont
sans doute ressorte de ressenti et cet
exercice extrêmement difficile à gérer à
la fois pour les enfants et pour les
enseignants pas duré toute la journée
jusqu'à ce soir et demain à partir de ce
soir est donc toute la journée de demain
une une journée de deuil national va
s'engager
oui on en reparlera aussi des enfants en
france cette fois la fin du journal vous
restez avec nous et tiennent pour
commenter cette image de george bush au
téléphone avec rudolph giuliani devant
les caméras de cnn
les téléspectateurs ont pu assister à la
conversation ils auront doter ses propos
du président américain
maintenant que la guerre nous a été
déclarée ou conduire le monde à la
victoire
alors est ce que cela signifie etienne
que après les heures de flottement cette
fois l'appareil d'état est bien en place
et que après la tristesse et la
détermination
oui je ne sais pas si on l'a bien vu sur
les images mais george bush lorsqu'il a
fait cette déclaration dans le bureau
ovale était littéralement au bord des
larmes extrêmement déterminé vous savez
de l'enquète qui a été engagée et une
enquête extrêmement vaste 7000 agents du
fbi nous dit-on sont engagés dans une
course contre la montre pour tenter de
d'essayer de localiser les personnes qui
seraient encore sur le territoire
américain qui serait donc partie
prenante de ce réseau d'une cinquantaine
de personnes puisqu'on estime à 50
personnes le nombre de d'un individu qui
aurait participé à ces différentes
attaques sur new york et sur washington
cinquante personnes parmi lesquelles
plusieurs pirates de l'air qui eux bien
évidemment sont décédés on va donner des
précisions dans un instant un
commentaire d'abord également sur cette
note que nous avons pu nous procurer une
note adressée à toutes les ambassades
par le département d'état
il y a quatre journaux en forme de mise
en garde à tous les citoyens américains
contre de possibles attaques à
l'étranger j'ai bien dit il ya quatre
jours c'était le 7 septembre et la note
cite nommément oussama ben laden et son
organisation
apparemment donc on avait conscience du
danger au département d'état simplement
on ne voyait pas forcément venir sur le
territoire américain
oui absolument vous savez ces mises en
garde
ôter aux citoyens américains résidant à
l'étranger sont absolument régulière il
y en a à peu près tous les tous les deux
mois elles sont publiques et cela
notamment depuis qu'il ya eu un attentat
au yémen contre un bâtiment de la de la
marine américaine ce qui peut être
nouveau effectivement c'est que le
réseau ben laden était cité nommément
ce qui laisserait à penser comme le
supposent d'ailleurs la plupart des
enquêteurs que cette fois ci encore et
cette fois ils ont frappé à l'intérieur
du territoire américain et bien c'est
bien le réseau ben laden qui
le premier suspect dans cette terrible
tragédie
alors voilà qui nous amène justement au
progrès de l'enquète vous le disiez
tienne elle a été très vite dès hier
soir nous vous disions que les kamikazes
étaient identifiés paul de genève il a
fallu à peine 48 heures aux agents du
fbi haye pour commencer à faire la
lumière sur les attentats selon certains
médias jusqu'à 50 personnes ont
participé de près ou de loin vous
attaque terroriste
la plupart des pirates de l'air serait
déjà identifiés selon le procureur
général
ils étaient 18 répartis dans les quatre
avions la piste la plus sérieuse à tout
d'abord mené les enquêteurs dans le sud
de la floride
six passagers des avions détourné avait
suivi des cours de pilotage ici parmi
eux cet homme et son frère mais
également celui ci mohammed atta lui on
sait qu'il a pris l'avion à boston
d'ailleurs sa voiture a été retrouvée
abandonnée près de l'aéroport dans le
coffre des documents d'une organisation
islamiste basée à hambourg
alertés par le fbi à la police allemande
a donc perquisitionné dans les logements
des suspects ils ont interpellé sept
femmes originaires du golfe
elle a été rapidement disculpé en
revanche un employé de l'aéroport de
hambourg est toujours interrogé la
sphère rebondit également en italie
des documents d'identité et des
uniformes d'employés de la compagnie
american airlines ont été volés au mois
d'avril dans un hôtel de rome
l' enquête commence à peine mais on peut
déjà constater que l'on a à faire un
réseau ramifications internationales
deux témoignages maintenant sur ce drame
le premier il a été diffusé par les
télévisions américaines il ne dure que
quelques secondes à celui d'une femme
coincée dans l'une des tours du world
trade center
juste avant son effondrement elle
parvient à joindre son mari écoutez
autre témoignage le vôtre bruno des
linges et non pas dellinger pardon
d'avoir écorché votre non merci d'être
en duplex avec nous à new york alors
vous avez échappé vous quelques secondes
près à la mort où étiez-vous exactement
au moment des impacts ce mardi matin
oui bonjour j'étais donc dans mon bureau
au world trade center au 47e étage et je
lisais et envoyer des emails lorsque
l'avion nous a frappés donc un étage au
dessus sur la façade qui est tout de
suite notre notre bureau ça a été un
très gros ce que j'imagine évidemment un
choc extraordinaire puisque le bâtiment
a vacillé très fortement il a aussi les
deux je ne sais pas combien de
centimètres mais nous n'arrivions à
peine avons nous tenir debout et qu'avez
vous pensé à ce moment là on a tout de
suite pensé que c'était une attaque
d'avion puisqu'on a entendu les
réacteurs s'approcher le bruit strident
des réacteurs et puis l'impact énorme
sur le sur la tour du world trade center
immédiatement j'ai demandé à mes
employés d'évacuer les bureaux et moi
même je suis resté pour sauvegarder les
données de notre entreprise
des données informatiques donc je
restais une dizaine de minutes un quart
d'heure supplémentaire et puis ensuite à
mon tour j'ai évacué les bureaux en
pensant revenir
vous avez entendu le deuxième choc
également non à ce moment là j'étais
dans les escaliers de descendre du world
trade center et je n'ai rien entendu
prend les escaliers d'ailleurs je tiens
à signaler que c'était une maîtrise de
soi individuel absolument exceptionnelle
les services de police les services des
pompiers qui montaient alors que nous
nous descendions des blessés gravement
brûlée qui descendait évacué en priorité
et personne ne bouge et de manière un
corps donné tout cela a été très très
très très organisée et très responsable
alors quand vous êtes arrivé dans la rue
quelques secondes plus tard seulement
l'immeuble s'est effondré c'est ça
absolument oui je me suis retournée
parce que j'aimais beaucoup ce bâtiment
et auquel j'étais très attaché j'y étais
depuis quatre ans je vais installer ma
société là dedans et c'est lorsque je me
suis retourné j'ai vu ce bâtiment en
flammes je n'en croyais pas mes yeux
et puis j'ai continué et à ce moment là
j'ai vu l'énorme vague de débris et de
gravats qui arrivait donc je suis
précipité à l'abri mes collaborateurs
ont vu d'ailleurs d'autres choses
horribles des gens qui sortaient des
fenêtres
c'était horrible comme com com comme
vision et quand j'entends le témoignage
de cette femme et que vous avez passé à
l'antenne juste avant que n'intervienne
si bouleversé parce que moi même j'ai
essayé d'appeler ma femme et je sens que
cette femme a ressenti vous avez eu peur
vous même pour votre vie non je n'ai
jamais eu peur pour ma vie sauf quand
j'ai vu arriver c'était énorme boule
c'est énorme boule monstrueuse de
gravats et de débris qui se précipitait
sur nous et là j'ai vraiment craint le
pire parce que je savais pas comment
l'éviter j'ai eu beaucoup de chance
était me protéger derrière un pilier et
au moment où je j'ai trouvé un chiffon
dans ma poche que je me suis appliqué
sur le nez et la bouche j'ai pu respirer
quelques instants supplémentaire parce
que l'air était devenu deux bouts de
matières n'y avait plus d'oxygène
et puis là quelqu'un je pense un agent
du fbi a eu un agent de la police qui
était dans partout dans le quartier m'a
tiré à l'intérieur d'une d'une
succursale de banque et l'ong là j'ai pu
recommencer à respirer quand on vous
voit bien sûr vous avez les raimu et
vous avez l'air aussi relativement
serein est-ce que vous avez l'impression
que ce qui s'est passé ce jour là ne
vous poursuivra pas trop suivra vous
avez par exemple j'entends des avions
passé au dessus de la tête et maintenant
je veux dire d'exemple quand un bruit
sourd je suis inquiet je regarde je
pouvais m'empêcher de regarder parce que
ce bruit du réacteur et dans mes
oreilles
et puis c'est surtout la pensée de tous
ces gens qui ceux qui ont péri dans le
world trade sainte notamment les
services de sécurité qui montait pour
nous aider alors que nous nous
descendions tout ça ce sont des
divisions terribles et ce bâtiment en
flammes qui symbolisait new york j'ai
habité pratiquement dix ans à new york
et j'étais très attaché à ce bâtiment je
crois que tous les new yorkais a été
très profondément attaché à ce bâtiment
et puis c'est aussi des années de
travail qui sont partis en fumée
vous comprenez bien que ça a des
conséquences
merci beaucoup bruno des linges et
d'avoir été avec nous à témoignages
maintenant propos de ce qui s'est passé
à l'intérieur d'un des avions détournés
celui qui s'est écrasé en pennsylvanie
les enquêteurs ont établi que jusqu'au
dernier moment des passagers s'était
battu avec les pirates de l'air pour
éviter le pire
zinédine boudaoud les terroristes n'ont
pas raté leur cible
à une exception près le boeing 757
d'united airlines qui s'est écrasé dans
un champ de pennsylvanie avait un tout
autre objectif la maison blanche où le
capitole était en fait visé par les
pirates de l'air une information livrée
par le ministère américain de la justice
mais les plans des terroristes pourrait
avoir été contrarié par des passagers
ce vol 93 a été détournée peu de temps
après son décollage de la banlieue new
yorkaise à passagers de 31 ans jeremy
glick appelle alors son épouse grâce à
son téléphone cellulaire
trois zones de type moyen oriental armés
de couteaux ont pris le contrôle de
l'avion dit-il à sa femme madame blick
lui apprend qu'un avion vient de
s'encastrer dans une des tours du world
trade center
jeremy glick aurait alors décidé de
passer à l'action
des bruits de lutte et des cris sont
enregistrées par le fbi ya une révolte
des passagers est elle à l'origine du
crash près de pittsburgh à 400 km de
washington
c'est l'hypothèse la plus probable
l'autre possibilité la destruction de
l'appareil par un avion de chasse et
catégoriquement démentie par le
département de la défense
et si les enquêteurs du fbi ayant acquis
la conviction que les pirates avaient
été formés au pilotage c'est parce que
les transpondeurs avait été désactivé
les transpondeurs ce sont ces appareils
qui émettent automatiquement des
messages d'identification vers la tour
de contrôle patrice pollet romuald bonne
en avant de frapper leurs cibles 3d
avions suicides avaient coupé ceci leur
transpondeur ici le bloc des instruments
radio radio navigation est ici l'eau
transpondeur où on affiche un code à
quatre chiffres en vol ce boîtier
électronique envoie vers les écrans des
aiguilleurs du ciel
trois informations le numéro de vol la
route et l'altitude et lorsque les
transpondeurs ont été coupées par les
terroristes
les avions disparu des écrans radar on
n'a aucune raison de le couper et si on
était amené à le couper immédiatement le
controversé de nous contacter pour
connaître les raisons pour lesquelles on
va le coupé mais depuis les cockpits
personne n'a répondu
dans ce cas précis la réglementation
internationale stipule qu'au bout de
cinq minutes on envoie la chasse une
décision impossible à prendre ici les
avions survolaient déjà les zones
habitées ce qui est sûr c'est que sur ce
qui s'est passé
le je dirais que le une fois que le peut
des pirates étaient à bord de l'avion
l'événement en terme de circulation
aérienne il était il était consommée et
il était imparable plus de transpondeurs
aucun contact radio
les terroristes se sont volontairement
isolé pour aller juste
de leurs actes criminels on revient
maintenant sur le donneur d'ordres
présumée dans un instant on découvrira
le témoignage d'un des proches tout ça
m'a ben laden
il saisit d'un mollah pakistanais le
pakistan je vous le rappelle est l'un
des trois seul état au monde à avoir
reconnu le régime des taliban qui
protège ben laden et sur les marchés là
bas en vente libre
on trouve des cd rom à la gloire du
terroriste bernard lebrun qu'est ce que
le pakistan pour cette minorité pro
islamiste qui manifestent bruyamment un
pays allié d'oussama ben laden et qui
lui sert de base arrière logistique
qu'est ce que le pakistan un pays en
voie de développement voisins de
l'afghanistan peuplé de 130 millions de
musulmans majoritairement acquis en cas
de répression d'éventuels dommages
collatéraux depuis ce matin dans les
échoppes du bazar
voici le cd rom que chacun peut acquérir
en forme de soutien au mouvement
d'oussama ben laden
au début on y vit une sourate du coran
ou les croyants craignez dieu et soyez
avec les puis rapidement apparaît ben
laden qui prêchent plus qu'il nous dise
quand il parle du prophète de médine en
des lieux saints autrement dit de sa
terre natale
l'arabie saoudite suivent les étapes de
la vie d'un parfait musulmans
combattants les moudjahidine les écoles
coraniques aux enfants en uniforme qui
s'entraînent sur le parcours du
combattant
et puis l'on passe à l'âge adulte voici
une base militaire filmé en afghanistan
pas très loin de la frontière
pakistanaise selon les experts le
milliardaire ben laden entretiendrait
une petite armée de trois à cinq mille
hommes
les slogans entendus par le sang nous
défendrons notre religion
le coran est dans nos mains nous défions
nos ennemis vannes citation
et un document particulièrement
intéressant maintenant donc avec le
témoignage de ce proche de ben laden ils
le rencontrent régulièrement et il
s'agit donc d'un mollah qui anime une
école coranique précisément au pakistan
à quelques dizaines de kilomètres de la
frontière afghane près de la ville de
peshawar
entretien signé sur place agnès
vahramian gilles jacquier obtenir une
interview du mollah samu ou lac c'est
accepter de répondre d'abord à ces
questions que vont faire les états unis
de montils aux étrangers une curiosité
polie dans cette école le mollah informé
80% de l'élite des taliban ici trois
mille élèves de 5 à 22 ans apprennent le
coran la charia la seule matière au
programme dans les dernières années
d'études
ces jeunes femmes viennent de kaboul ou
de kandahar là où se cache oussama ben
laden le mollah connais bien l'ennemi
public numéro un aux états unis
il affirme ne pas l'avoir vu récemment
mais il sourit des contradictions
américaine les américains savent que ou
save a été un héros lui est respectée
parce qu'il a combattu les soviétiques à
l'époque en afghanistan se lasse après
la guerre sainte est aujourd'hui en
palestine et au cachemire il ya aussi
une guerre sainte de cette fois pour les
américains c'est du terrorisme
le mollah confirme oussama ben laden vit
retranché dans les montagnes selon lui
le milliardaire aurait promis aux
talibans de ne pas les gêner de ne pas
ajouter à la misère de leur peuple
les talibans contrôlent ses activités
ils lui ont dit de ne pas contacter les
médias de ne pas prendre la parole
il n'a plus de moyens de communication
ils l'ont isolé il ne peut plus rien
faire
les américains devraient être contents
et remercié les talibans le mollah les
professeurs les élèves condamne ce
qu'ils appellent une tragédie mais nous
souffrons distille aussi de voir les
morts de palestine ou du cachemire il
ajoute un musulman n'a pas pu faire ça
l'ennemi est venu de l'intérieur
on nous explique encore que l'on
enseigne ici la peine et le respect des
chrétiens gloire et en coin que le monde
musulman ne veut pas la guerre
peshawar et sur la frontière avec
l'afghanistan et abrite de nombreux
réfugiés qui ont fui kaboul la guerre
civile et la pauvreté dans la rue
afghans et pakistanais attendre avec
crainte la réponse américaine dans les
cafés on suit nonchalamment les derniers
développements aux états unis
le pakistan contre on surveille les
talibans sur son territoire mais ils les
utilisent aussi dans son conflit
notamment avec l'inde sur le cachemire
cette proximité pour être aujourd'hui le
mettre en difficulté
oui le président pakistanais a rencontré
aujourd'hui l'ambassadeur américain pour
l'assurer de son soutien dans la lutte
antiterroriste le pakistan on l'a
compris souvent accusé de double jeu
donc par les observateurs à paris aussi
les magistrats antiterroristes penche
sur l'organisation d'oussama ben laden
une enquête officielle a été ouverte
hier sur d'éventuels liens entre les
réseaux islamistes français et les
attentats américain audrey goutard la
première fois que les policiers français
ressentent la force de frappe de ben
laden c'est en 94
un commando est arrêté après ce sont des
jeunes des banlieues françaises envoyées
de leur pays d'origine pour mener une
opération terroriste contre un hôtel de
marrakech
derrière eux plein déjà l'ombre du
milliardaire saoudien
deux ans plus tard en 96 le nom de ben
laden apparaît à nouveau lors de
l'arrestation d'un commando à roubaix
parmi les interpellés
les français converti à l'islam entraîné
militairement en bosnie en afghanistan
le milliardaire saoudien vise les
intérêts américains partout dans le
monde
la france n'est donc pas à l'abri d'un
attentat les services de renseignements
n'ont d'ailleurs déjouer un récemment au
coeur de strasbourg en décembre
quatre islamistes sont arrêtés en
allemagne ils détiennent une vidéo un
repérage précis verrue de la ville leur
chef
- ben med sacrias est arrêté peu après
c'est un proche de ben laden
auteur de plusieurs attentats anti
américains à en croire les juges
antiterroristes la france ne serait pas
un objectif pour ben laden juste une
plaque tournante
dès ce matin ils ont été saisis d'une
enquête son but étudier les liens entre
les réseaux islamistes français et
l'attentât aux états unis et les
enquêteurs français se pencheront
peut-être sur ses sites internet qui
font la promotion d'oussama ben laden ou
d'autres leaders islamistes ces sites
sont visibles en français ils font
ouvertement l'apologie du terrorisme
l'association antiraciste j'accuse avait
alerté la justice à ce propos dès le
mois de juillet dernier florence bukiya
françois privat très documenté souvent
réactualisé ce site internet est
dangereux il donne des conseils
pratiques aux internautes
il leur suffit de cliquer ici pour
apprendre comment s'entraîner pour le
jihad la guerre sainte
il interprète aussi de façon très
tendancieuse de multiples sourates du
coran
il fait par exemple l'apologie de
l'attentât suicide et ordonne aux
musulmans de rechercher le martyre et
d'infliger des pertes à l'ennemi en
juillet dernier l'association j'accuse
à signaler la dangerosité de ce site
internet au parquet de paris après avoir
fait sa propre enquête
nous avons utilisé le ciel qu'on appelle
un traceur pouvoir qu'ils pouvaient se
cacher derrière soucis que nous avons
localisé le dépositaire le responsable
du domaine st comme fenêtre et quelqu'un
qui vit dans la creuse et nous avons
trouvé quelque chose de très intéressant
en fait la société qui héberge suicide
n'est pas une société française mais une
société américaine
localisé dans la vie de millions dans le
connecticut cet avocat soupçonne donc la
société qui gère ce site en france de
n'être qu'une société écran nous avons
tenté de rencontrer son gérant ici à
sardent au coeur de la creuse
mais l'homme qui a déposé le nom du
domaine st.com à fermer boutique il ya
plus de six mois il se fait depuis très
discret pour l'instant aucune plainte
n'a été déposée contre lui les mesures
de sécurité décidées au lendemain de
l'attentât aux etats-unis en tout cas
sont appliqués à la lettre alain richard
était cet après midi en visite au
commandement de la défense aérienne à
taverny en région parisienne c'est le
lieu
centraliser toutes les informations
c'est également là que seront prises les
décisions en cas de nécessité
d'intervention des avions de combat
alors quel est le dispositif explication
cette fois au pc aériens de lyon
benoît gadret philippe évêques la base
aérienne du mont verdun est un peu comme
un iceberg à la surface on ne distingue
que les antenne radar mais à 100 mètres
sous terre c'est une petite ville mallet
d'interminables gallerey que l'on
découvre mille militaires safari fils
jour et nuit
il surveille le trafic aérien civil et
militaire du quart sud est de la france
ce type de matériel nous permet de voir
rapidement s'il y avait quelque chose
d'anormal sur un avion
il faut savoir que pour les aéronefs qui
survole l'espace aérien national nous
possédons toutes les informations
plantes ball qui nous sont communiquées
par l'aviation civile en cas d'alliance
suspect le contrôleur a le pouvoir
d'ordonner le décollage d'un avion de
chasse a connu des pilotes de chasse
sont actuellement en ahl il ne leur faut
en général que quelques minutes pour
rejoindre l'avion comportement suspect
et informer le contrôleur aérien l'armée
de l'air a mis en alerte plus d'avions
que d'habitude
nous avons une dizaine d'avions en
alerte aux réparties sur cinq bases en
france afin de mieux prendre en compte
la totalité de l'espace aérien et
surtout d'aller au plus vite reconnaître
une menace potentielle en cas de danger
l'information est transmise en temps
réel aux centres de taverny qui l'a
relais à l'hôtel matignon
depuis 48 heures plusieurs avions civils
ont fait l'objet d'une reconnaissance
aérienne à chaque fois de fausses
alertes
à propos d'avion l'espace aérien
américain est réouvert peu à peu voici
le premier avion qui a pu décoller ça se
passe à columbus dans l'ohio
il s'agit bien sûr d'un vol intérieur
les vols internationaux restent très
limitées air france avait prévu trois
long-courriers cet après-midi finalement
ils n'ont pas pu décoller reportage
cyrille devaud bernard connor michel
levasseur la ruée vers l'or pour les
centaines d'américains bloqués à paris
depuis deux jours 15 heures environ à
l'aéroport de roissy air france annonce
le départ de trois vols vers atlanta
washington et new york
embarquement immédiat
c'est que ni les vacances sont finies
alors nous voulons vivre entre hermann
fille et son sax et je veux être avec
elle des personnes ils ont beaucoup
aidés on était vraiment content
d'apprécier en est extrait unis pourtant
arrivé à la porte de l'avion demi-tour
vols annulés
les états unis viennent tout juste
d'annoncer qu'ils exigent de nouvelles
normes de sécurité renforcées en
attendant le détail les autorités
françaises préfèrent différer les
décollages retour à la case départ pour
tous les passagers
déçue très en colère je dois rentrer à
la maison pour prendre des nouvelles de
mon mari ils viennent encore d'annuler
je comprends les soucis de sécurité
je préfère qu'ils gagnent écrit tout et
qui contrôle tout le monde du mieux
possible même si je dois rester trois
jours de plus je préfère rentrer sains
et saufs faut le prendre du bon côté
paris jusqu'à nouvel ordre toutes les
compagnies sont suspendus à
l'autorisation du gouvernement américain
pour reprendre leurs vols vers les états
unis
le point maintenant sur le plan
vigipirate je vous le disais on a
recensé une vingtaine d' alerte à la
bombe pour la seule ville de paris
thomas dandois vincent ferreira
c'est une alerte de plus toute la
journée les services de déminage
sillonne paris direction cette fois la
gare montparnasse pour un véhicule
suspect
une fois encore il s'agit d'une fausse
alerte par précaution les démineurs
inspectent quand même la voiture sous
l'oeil sceptique ou ans qui est des
habitants du quartier la voiture
plusieurs cours un colis suspect
quelques rues plus loin et c'est reparti
[Musique]
par avance à un niveau
un autre appel sur les quais de la gare
montparnasse
c'est un vanity caisse ou plutôt ce
qu'il en reste sans doute oublié par un
voyageur voiture ou colis suspect alerte
à la bombe fantaisistes
les démineurs de paris sont intervenus
une vingtaine de fois dans la journée
c'est cinq fois plus qu'en temps normal
on en parlait tout à l'heure avec
etienne leenhardt depuis deux jours et
demi comme pratiquement toutes les
télévisions du monde nous diffusons ces
images terribles du world trade center
et du pentagone
de l'avis de tous les spécialistes les
psychiatres notamment ces images peuvent
choquer profondément les enfants voir
les adolescents des psychiatres qui
conseille de parler avec d'expliquer
alors comment réagit style témoignages
recueillis à rouen à caen à montpellier
à choisy le roi dans tous les âges et
rassemblés par nabila taboury et diane
richard l'impression que c'est tiré d'un
film d'horreur
parce que voir que la plus grande
puissance du monde ça s'écroule comme ça
par rapport à un petit groupe de
terroristes
ça fait bizarre j'allume la télé et je
vois d'un coup j'allume et je voyais ma
petit séjour
alors moi je n'étais pas du tout au
courant alors ça m'a fait drôle mais ian
moore mienne gens s'en moquent sont
morts à cause de cette bêtise à
le vol 77 d'american airlines parti de
washington n'arrivera jamais à los
angeles
ces trucs ce parce que il ya des
milliers de gens qui n'ont rien fait d
innocents et qu'ils ont péri dans ces
attentats
il ya eu plusieurs guerres la première
guerre mondiale la deuxième guerre
mondiale est peut-être que maintenant ça
sera la troisième et ça m'a fait peur en
fait on a vraiment l'impression que
c'est des jeux vidéo que c'est géré tué
parce que quand on voit les avions
commandes qui commet qui rendent dans
les tous et tout ça on n'a pas
l'impression si la réalité on pressent
que c'est un vrai film quoi les
musulmans et nappes qui sont et qui sont
qui sont pas corrects et y en a qui sont
bons et j'oserais dire il me chez les
chrétiens aussi c'est comme ça et
cathodique et voilà les bouddhas et
juive séparés pour qu'ils réfléchissent
et tout ça et qu'ils réfléchissent pia
et il cherche qui tue pas qu'il faut pas
bombarder direct on a encore des enfants
puis on essaye de deux d'avoir un monde
où sans violence au racisme et puis ça
et cissé continue à avoir des références
comme sa base simple décourageant filles
de toutes les parties du monde les
témoignages de sympathie pour les
victimes et pour le peuple américain
sont arrivés à new york et à washington
l'occident resserrent les rangs promet
même une solidarité active contre le
terrorisme même les chinois aujourd'hui
sont allés dans le même sens on
attendait cette question si on attendait
cette réaction de pékin depuis deux
jours donc geste de solidarité geste
politique mais geste de compassion
également à paris ce soir une cérémonie
oecuménique était organisée à l'église
américaine en présence des représentants
des principales religions
beaucoup de dirigeants français dont
jacques chirac et lionel jospin philippe
boisserie philippe lui dit s'il fallait
une image pour résumer le message porté
par tous ceux venus se recueillir ce
serait sûrement ce choeur arboré par une
petite américaine un message d'amour est
un devoir de mémoire pour tous
je viens de new york encore des habits
qu'on pensait pas la famille nos pas
nous sauver
alors c'est tout à fait normal
côte à côte le président de la
république et le premier ministre pour
une cérémonie où toutes les obédiences
toutes les nationalités se retrouvait
derrière le message d'accueil du pasteur
de l'église américaine
oui comme tu sais nous sommes venus dire
non à la haine non à la violence
car dans tous les esprits cours l'idée
que l'extrémisme religieux pourrait être
à l'origine de ce drame
le monde tant souffert des guerres de
religion pour qu'ensemble
à partir d'aujourd'hui nous bâtissions
les religions de la paix quiconque tue
une vie innocente c'est comme s'il avait
tué toute l'humanité et quiconque sauve
une vie c'est comme s'il avait sauvé
toute l'humanité
si les coeurs des hommes ne changent pas
alors le monde est condamné livré au
pire de ce qu'il peut inventer
dehors une foule nombreuse était venue
pour se recueillir pour partager à la
fin de la célébration personnalités et
anonymes se sont retrouvés comme pour
dire plus jamais ça
autre image initiative pour la première
fois dans l'histoire de la
grande-bretagne l'hymne américain et non
pas l'hymne britannique a été jouée
pendant la relève de la garde au palais
de buckingham
de nombreux touristes américains en
larmes et y ont assisté
le proche orient maintenant hier nous
vous montrions cette image de yasser
arafat cherchant à compenser l'effet
désastreux des images des palestiniens
au liban
un manifestant leur joie après ces
attentats yasser arafat qui donnait son
sang et bien aujourd'hui il a imposé
également plusieurs minutes de silence
dans les écoles notamment claude son
père jean françois renaud sur place
une minute de silence dans toutes les
écoles palestiniennes à la mémoire des
victimes des attentats aux états unis un
peu partout ce matin à gaza et en
cisjordanie ont eu lieu des
rassemblements des colliers plus ou
moins spontanés en solidarité avec le
peuple américain depuis deux jours
yasser arafat le président de l'autorité
palestinienne fait tout son possible
pour améliorer l'image des palestiniens
auprès des états unis il ne veut surtout
pas que l'opinion internationale fasse
un amalgame entre islam et terrorisme
hier devant les caméras dans un geste
très symbolique
il a donné son sang bénéfice des
victimes des attentats
aujourd'hui il appelle les nations
arabes à se joindre à la coalition
internationale contre le terrorisme
plus question aujourd'hui d'offrir au
monde des images des palestiniens
sautant de joie après les attentats
l'enjeu est important car au même moment
ariel sharon multiplie ses opérations
territoires palestiniens comme ici à
jéricho le premier ministre israélien
tente de son côté de profiter au maximum
de la situation
ce matin il a déclaré nous avons notre
ben laden à nous il s'appelle yasser
arafat le reste de l'actualité en bref
on est toujours dans l'incertitude en ce
qui concerne l'état de santé du
commandant massoud en afghanistan dont
on parlait tout à l'heure le commandant
massoud victime récemment d'un attentat
pas d'indication mais on apprend qu'il a
été remplacé à la tête de son mouvement
l'alliance du nord par l'un de ces
second le général l'amour ahmad faqir en
france la corse le chef de file des
nationalistes à l'assemblée jean guy
talamoni interrogé comme prévu
aujourd'hui comme témoin par le juge
antiterroriste gilbert thiel dans le
cadre de l' enquête sur l'assassinât du
nationaliste jean michel rossi une
audition peu productives a déclaré
l'intéressé qu'indique qui ne connais
rien à cette affaire en l'écoutent
adopté une position de principe qui est
une position non pas judiciaire mais
politique
qui est de marquer mon désaccord avec
notamment la médiatisation de cette
convocation et je m'ai fait en refusant
de répondre aux questions qui m'étaient
posées
je crois que ça n'est pas loyal je pense
qu'il s'agit d'une manipulation et que
cette manipulation causé un tort
considérable au mouvement auquel
j'appartiens est également en possession
du bâtiment
la condamnation de philippe douste blazy
à 20 mille francs d'amendé le député
maire de toulouse a été reconnu coupable
de recel d'un fichier confidentiel de
parents d'élèves pendant la campagne des
élections municipales mais il reste
éligible l'annulation de l'élection de
jean louis barberot maire communiste de
champigny dans le val-de-marne
il lui a reproché d'avoir invalidé
d'autorité une liste de la gauche
alternative aux dernières élections
le pirate informatique mafiaboy condamné
à huit mois de détention
mafia boy et le surnom de ce jeune
canadien à l'origine de la plus grande
vague d' attaque lancée en février 2000
contre des sites internet américains
le groupe chimique allemand bayer vient
d'être blanchi par une enquête
administrative dans la sphère du
médicament anticholestérol soupçonné
d'être à l'origine des nombreux décès
dans le monde
l' agence allemande des médicaments
estiment que bayer avait fourni de
manière satisfaisante des informations
sur ce médicament
en bref toujours elisabeth guigou
annonce la nuit dernière qu'elle porte
de 40000 à 45000 les créations d'emplois
dans la fonction publique hospitalière
à l'occasion du passage aux 35 heures
force ouvrière la cgt et sud
maintiennent la journée d'action pour le
20 septembre
et puis notez enfin que la date limite
du paiement du troisième tiers
provisionnels de l'impôt a été repoussée
au lundi 17 septembre au lieu de samedi
prochain c'est ce qu'annonce bercy fin
de cette édition je vous en rappelle les
deux principaux titres le premier bilan
à new york 4857 mort ou disparu sous les
décombres encore fumantes du world trade
center
on estime à 200 morts pour l'instant
chiffres provisoires le bilan à
washington
et puis la piste remonté par le fbi il
passe par l'allemagne
deux des kamikazes auraient séjourné à
hambourg
en france aussi les enquêtes sur les
réseaux islamistes a peut-être en
liaison avec ces attentats
ces enquêtes ont été ouvertes à suivre
la météo isabelle martinet le point
route valérie maurice l'info sur france
2 elle continue toute la soirée
à 21h10 envoyé spécial en direct
présenté par françoise joly et guilaine
chenu spécial attentats usa campus
ensuite avec guillaume durant une heure
le journal de la nuit jean claude
renault demain à 7h40
roland vers roland jacquard aux 4
vérités télé matin dès 6h30 13 heures
daniel bilalian demain 20 heures ce sera
à béatrice schönberg tout de suite vous
avez rendez vous avec et olivier
mazerolle et alain duhamel tour
reçoivent dans questions ouvertes valéry
giscard d'estaing
[Musique]